Hi everyone. I'm Jim,
a software engineer in Tokyo.
Thank you for joining my session.
Today we will learn about neural
networks.
We will build a small neural network
from scratch using TypeScript.
This session is for engineers who use AI
and want to understand how it works
inside.
All right. Let's get started.
>> Today, we need a small problem to solve
with our neural network.
For that, we're going to use XOR.
XOR is often used as a classic beginner
example for neural networks because it
looks simple, but it cannot be solved by
a single straight line.
So, it's a nice way to understand why we
need multiple layers.
Let's quickly review XOR. XOR returns
true when two inputs are different and
false when they are the same.
So, false and false gives us false.
False and true gives us true. True and
false gives us true. And true and true
gives us false.
On the screen, you can see the
TypeScript version. It is just a small
function that takes two Boolean values
and returns whether they are different.
Very simple.
Now, let's try to make a neural network
learn this behavior.
So, what does it mean to implement XOR
with a neural network? In the code we
just saw, we directly wrote the rule.
If the two values are different, return
true.
But with a neural network, we don't
write that rule directly. Instead, we
take input values, multiply them by
weights, add biases, pass the result
through an activation function, and get
an output. In other words, instead of
hardcoding the rule, we let the network
learn the right weights from data.
So, how How that calculation actually
work?
Let's say we have an input like zero and
one.
First, we multiply the input by weights.
Then we add a bias.
Let's say the value before the
activation function is 0.6.
In a neural network, we usually don't
use this value directly as the final
output. Instead, we pass it through an
activation function.
In this example, we'll use the sigmoid
function.
The sigmoid function converts any input
value into a value between zero and one.
For example, if the value before
activation is 0.6, the sigmoid output is
around 0.65.
So, the important point is this.
We calculate a value using weights and
biases.
Then we use the sigmoid function to
convert that value into the range
between zero and one.
That converted value becomes the output
of the layer.
Now, let's look at the code. On the
screen, you can see a class called
tensor. I'll explain it later, but for
now you can think of it as a class for
matrix calculations. In one layer of a
neural network, we first calculate the
dot product of the input and the weight.
Then we add the bias.
The code on the screen does exactly
that. It takes the input, applies the
weight, adds the bias, and stores the
result as the value before activation.
Next, we apply the activation function.
The activated value becomes the final
output of this layer.
So, the basic flow of a neural network
layer is take the input, multiply it by
weights, add a bias, pass it through an
activation function, return the output.
That's the forward pass.
Now, let's say the output we got is
0.65,
but the correct answer is 1.0. You might
think
we wanted 1.0, but we only got 0.65.
That's still pretty far off, right?
Exactly.
At this point, the network's output is
not correct yet. So, what should we
change? We need to change the weights
and biases.
A neural network learns by comparing its
output with the correct answer, and then
updating its weights and biases little
by little. For example, if the output is
0.65 and the target is 1.0, the
difference is 0.35.
To measure this error, we subtract the
target value from the output value.
On the screen, you can see this written
as output minus target. Here, Y means
the output, and T means the target. But,
this value can be positive or negative.
So, to make the size of the error easier
to handle, we square it. In practice, we
often write the squared error with 1/2
in front. The 1/2 is there because when
we differentiate this function, the two
from the square cancels out with the
1/2.
So, the derivative becomes a little
cleaner. This is called the squared
error.
Now, the next question is, how do we
know in which direction and by how much
we should update the weights?
This is where derivatives come in. A
derivative tells us the slope of a
function at a specific point. In other
words, it tells us which direction the
function is moving and how strongly it
is moving in that direction.
In neural networks, we use derivatives
to figure out how each parameter should
change in order to reduce the error.
Let's look at the error function again.
On the screen, you can see the squared
error formula. Here, Y is the final
output after the activation function.
If we differentiate this error function
with respect to Y, we get Y minus T.
So, the difference between the output Y
and the target T becomes the gradient at
the output side.
Next, we pass this gradient backward
through the sigmoid function, the
weights, and the biases. This process is
called backpropagation. Backpropagation
uses the chain rule. A neural network is
basically a chain of functions. We
multiply by weights, we add a bias, we
apply an activation function, we
calculate the error. Because these
operations are connected, we need to
connect their derivatives, too. That's
what the chain rule does. In the code,
this is the backward part. First, we
calculate the difference between the
output and the target. In the code on
the screen, this is stored as the
gradient with respect to the output.
Next, we go backwards through the
activation function. For the sigmoid
function, the derivative can be written
as the output times 1 minus the output.
So, we multiply the incoming gradient by
the derivative of the sigmoid function.
That gives us the gradient with respect
to the value before activation.
Then, we use this gradient to calculate
the gradients for the input, weights,
and bias.
We take the dot product of the
transposed input and the gradient. For
the value that we pass back to the
previous layer, we use the gradient and
the transposed weight.
For the bias, if we process one sample
at a time, we can use this gradient
directly as the bias gradient. If we
process multiple samples as a batch, we
usually sum the gradients across the
sample dimension.
Now, we have gradients for the weights
and biases. To update the parameters, we
multiply the gradients by the learning
rate. The learning rate controls how big
each update step should be.
But, one important thing is this. The
gradient points in the direction where
the error increases. So, if we want to
reduce the error, we move in the
opposite direction.
That means we subtract the learning rate
scaled gradient from the current weight
and bias.
If the learning rate is too large, the
updates can become unstable. If it's too
small, learning becomes very slow.
By repeating this process many times,
the neural network gradually gets closer
to the correct answer.
But, there is one more important issue.
If we use only one layer, the network
can only represent a linear decision
boundary. XOR cannot be separated by a
single straight line. So, a single layer
network cannot solve XOR well.
That's why we use multiple layers.
For example, the first layer can
transform the input into a different
feature space. Then, the second layer
can use that transformed representation
to produce the final output. By stacking
layers like this, the network can
represent more complex functions. This
is the basic idea behind multi-layer
neural networks.
Now, let's look at a working example. At
the beginning of training, the outputs
are not very stable. You might see
values around 0.4 or 0.5. So, the
network is basically guessing.
But, as training continues, the outputs
gradually move closer to the correct
answers. Eventually, we get something
like this.
For 0 XOR 0, the output becomes close to
0, maybe around 0.01.
For 0 XOR 1, the output becomes close to
1, maybe around 0.98.
For 1 XOR 0, the output also becomes
close to 1. And for 1 XOR 1, the output
becomes close to 0.
So, the network has learned the XOR
behavior from data.
That's the high-level flow of how this
tiny neural network works.
From here, let's look at some of the
math and TypeScript implementation
details behind each block.
First, let's quickly review derivatives.
A derivative tells us the rate of change
of a function at a specific point. In
other words, it tells us the slope. In
neural networks, we need to know which
direction to move the weights and biases
in order to reduce the error.
Derivatives help us understand that
direction and the size of the change.
Let's use the function x squared.
Suppose we want to know the slope at
some point x. To do that, we look at the
value of the function at x and also at a
point just a tiny bit ahead, x + h.
The rate of change can be written as the
value at x + h minus the value at x
divided by h. If our function is x
squared, this becomes x + h squared
minus x squared divided by h. When we
expand that expression, the x squared
terms cancel out. Then, we divide by h.
Finally, when h gets extremely small,
basically approaching zero, the h term
disappears. So, we get 2x. That means
the derivative of x squared is 2x.
That's the basic idea of
differentiation. Next, let's look at
matrix calculations. Neural networks use
matrix operations a lot because inputs,
weights, and biases are easier to handle
in matrix form. Let's start with
addition. Matrix addition is simple. We
just add each pair of matching elements.
For example, if we have a 2 by 2 matrix
with 1, 2, 3, and 4, and another 2 by 2
matrix with 5, 6, 7, and 8, then the
result is 6, 8, 10, and 12. In the
source code, this is also
straightforward. We loop through the
arrays, pick the matching values, and
add them together. Subtraction works the
same way. We subtract matching elements.
Next is element-wise multiplication.
This is not matrix multiplication. It
simply multiplies values at the same
position. Next, let's look at the dot
operation, or matrix multiplication.
This is one of the most important
operations in neural networks. In matrix
multiplication, we combine rows from the
left matrix with columns from the right
matrix. For example, suppose we have the
matrix A. The first row is 1 and 2. The
second row is 3 and 4. And we have
another matrix B. The first value is 1.
The second value is 2. First, we take
the first row of A, which is 1 and 2,
and combine it with the first column of
B, which is 1 and 2. We calculate 1 * 1
+ 2 * 2. That gives us 5. Then we take
the second row of A, which is 3 and 4,
and combine it with the same column of
B. We calculate 3 * 1 + 4 * 2. That
gives us 11. So, the result is a column
with 5 and 11. For matrix
multiplication, the number of columns in
the left matrix must match the number of
rows in the right matrix. So, if the
left matrix is 2 by 2, the right matrix
must have two rows. We prepare an array
for the result. Then we loop over the
rows of the left matrix and the columns
of the right matrix. It looks a little
complicated at first, but the idea is
simple. Take a row and a column,
multiply matching values, and add them
up.
Next is transpose. Transpose means
swapping rows and columns. For example,
if we have a matrix where the first row
is one and two, and the second row is
three and four, after transposing it,
the first row becomes one and three, and
the second row becomes two and four.
Rows become columns, and columns become
rows. We use transpose often during back
propagation, especially when calculating
gradients.
Next is scaling. Scaling means
multiplying every element in a matrix by
the same value. For example, if we have
a matrix with one, two, three, and four,
and scale it by two, the result becomes
two, four, six, and eight. Very simple.
We use this kind of operation when
applying the learning rate to gradients.
Finally, let's look at the sigmoid
function. The sigmoid function is
written as one divided by one plus e to
the power of negative X.
Here, e is Euler's number, also called
Napier's constant, and it's
approximately 2.718.
E to the power of negative X means one
divided by e to the power of X. The
sigmoid function always returns a value
between zero and one, no matter what
input value we give it. That makes it
useful when we want the output to behave
like close to zero or close to one.
Another nice thing about sigmoid is that
it's derivative is simple. If the output
of the sigmoid function is Y, then it's
derivative is Y * 1 - Y. This simple
derivative makes it convenient for back
propagation. You can create similar
shaped functions using different bases,
but the standard sigmoid function uses
the natural exponential function with e.
That's because it works nicely with
differentiation and makes the learning
calculation cleaner.
I hope this session helped me to you
understand how have basic neural
networks.
You can find source code and more
examples like CNNs and RNNs
on the GitHub repository below.
Thank you for watching. Bye-bye.